je peux vous dire qu'on va se faire
c'est un financeur est perçue d'avoir
dénoncé l'arnaqué et le combat qu'est ce
qui démontre houba houba y dénonce le
fait que des personnes se servent de la
de leur notoriété pour vendre n'importe
quoi à n'importe qui et c'est pas juste
une star de la télé réalité à qui tout
de suite on va la prendre en main on va
lui créer un compte on va même créé des
abonnés et puis on va lui faire vendre
des produits que souvent elle même ne
connaît absolument pas mais puisqu'elle
a un crédit auprès de ses followers et
avant de ses spectateurs eh bien les
gens vont acheter parfois se ruiner
parce qu'on est sur une population
crédules fragile ce sont nos jeunes ce
sont nos enfants parfois s'il vaut
spectateurs sur bien sûr et qui savent
pas se réguler pas à ça et puisqu'il ya
quelqu'un qui en qu'ils ont confiance
quelqu'un qui connaissent quelqu'un qui
fait partie de leur quotidien